Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank,"
Daniel Lubetzky, the founder
of the groundbreaking
snack company "KIND,"
returns to the Tank.
You're one of the most
impressive people
I've seen in a very long time.
Marcotte: This tiny object
changed everything.
Sharks,
let us break the ice.
Your logo is so close
to Scrub Daddy's.
I'm doing this alone.
You've got to sell, man.
I will never not know
how to make money.
That doesn't matter!
I want to buy
the entire company.
We would take a million.
Bam.
You want how much?
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a product designed to
relieve stress
and promote relaxation.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Kaylin Marcotte.
I am from New York City,
and I'm here seeking $500,000
in exchange for
5% of my company.
Wow.
Stress and mental exhaustion
can wreak havoc on our minds,
bodies, and relationships.
Five years ago,
I was working around the clock
at an early start‐up
and was looking
for a new and healthy way
to unwind and unplug.
I tried meditation, yoga,
even essential oils
without much success.
And then this tiny object
changed everything.
A jigsaw puzzle.
Focusing on one simple task
and building something
piece by piece
felt both relaxing
and rewarding.
I lost the urge
to check my phone
and truly cleared my head.
Problem was, all
the puzzles on the market
are outdated, uninspired,
and, well, kind of lame.
[ Laughter ]
Sharks, let me
introduce you to Jiggy ‐‐
modern puzzles with a mission.
Each Jiggy features unique art
by an emerging female artist
from around the world.
A percentage of every sale
goes directly to that artist,
empowering these
up‐and‐coming creatives
and giving them a platform
to showcase their work.
Each puzzle comes
in a reusable glass jar
and includes simple tools
to preserve your work of art.
When the final piece
is in place,
simply spread our puzzle glue
over the pieces
and transform it into a
beautifully crafted art print.
We are reinventing
the humble jigsaw puzzle
and reconnecting people
with both mindfulness and art,
one piece at a time.
Now, who's ready to
get Jiggy with us?
In front of you,
you have some puzzles,
each a different artwork.
Oh, it's beautiful.
Cuban: That's cool.
The pieces come in this
reusable glass jar.
We've seen people use them as
a cookie jar or a flower vase.
Greiner: It's pretty.
Behind it is
a tube of puzzle glue,
and then in front is
a gold straight‐edge tool.
It helps spread the glue.
How long does it take?
These pieces are tiny.
How many pieces
are in a typical puzzle?
Probably 500 to 1,000.
Our kids and I, my wife
and I love doing puzzles,
but you need to
solve one puzzle for me.
How did you get
to this valuation?
Because it really is
very intimidating.
Yeah.
Yeah, so, we just launched
nine months ago.
In the last nine months, we have
done $1.6 million in sales.
What? Wow.
Cuban: Good for you.
This first year,
we're going to do 2.25.
We're profitable.
Tell me,
did you do that alone?
Yes, I'm a one‐woman show.
Oh, my gosh.
And you own 100%?
Yeah.
Bootstrapped, no debt.
Good for you.
No investors.
No equity partners.
Very impressive.
Your timing was unique,
lucky, and perfect,
because all of a sudden,
you're into COVID.
Everybody's at home,
and you're getting
this huge ramp.
Marcotte: Right.
What was your profit
on that $1.6 million?
We're netting 40%,
so this year
on a two and a quarter,
we're gonna make 900.
That's unbelievable.
Wow!
So why do you
need us?
So, I'm doing this alone.
I'm here for a partner.
The incumbents in this space
are following a retail,
kind of old‐school playbook.
No one is digitally native.
No one is competing in SEO
and digital marketing.
It's like a land grab right now.
You're doing it
all online?
This first year is going to be
60% D2C, 40% wholesale.
We were approached
earlier this year
by an upscale national retailer,
and we're going to be
in 215 stores.
What does
a puzzle sell for?
So, we retail these
for $40 and $48.
Costs you what
to make them?
$10.
And how much
does the artist get?
The artist makes, on average,
$3,000 to $5,000
for our first run.
What percentage of
the buyers now are repeat?
First, we surveyed
our customers.
We are expanding this category.
Half of our customers had never
bought a jigsaw puzzle before.
Ever?
25% indicated 8 to 10
on a scale of 10
that they would want
even something monthly.
25%?
Like a subscription membership.
You're suggesting there might be
a subscription model to this?
Yes. We would curate
new, monthly images.
What we're seeing is
people who do return
are buying, on average,
four puzzles.
What happens when
COVID is gone?
These macro trends that
inspired me to start this,
of self‐care and analog,
those have been around
for a long time.
We did a quarter million in our
first four months, pre‐COVID,
and then we sold out.
Wow.
You are great
at branding.
Thank you.
Kaylin, first of all,
you're a supernova.
Thank you.
I'm trying to remember
if we've ever had somebody
go from zero
to your kind of numbers.
This is
a great business,
but at the $10 million
value that you're implying,
I have to believe
that your sales are gonna be
tens of millions
for me to recoup
my investment.
I don't see it continuing
at that trajectory.
I think people will
move on to other things.
I'm out.
Kaylin, you're
incredibly impressive.
One of the most impressive
people I've seen
in a very long time.
Thank you.
I do think that you're
benefiting from the COVID push,
and the valuation
is not the right valuation,
but I also don't think
you need a Shark.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
And best wishes.
You know, I'm struggling with
how much of this is sustainable,
post‐COVID.
I would give you an offer,
but I'd have to
mitigate my risk,
and I'd do it this way.
[ Chuckles ]
I would give you $100,000
for 15% equity
and a loan
for $400,000 at 10%
for 36 months.
[ Herjavec laughs ]
Okay.
And ‐‐ Well, I don't hear you
putting up a check.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
You are a Shark.
What I don't know is
tomorrow morning,
vaccine, people get on
with their lives,
and they're saying,
"What was that puzzle?"
I mean,
that's the problem.
I don't ‐‐
Cuban: You know, as crazy
as Mr. Wonderful is,
he's right in
one respect.
The problem is
just the valuation.
You've got to make
$10 million in cash flow
that you distribute
in order for that 5% of that
to come back
as $500,000 to me.
Look, there are
a lot of great branders.
There's a lot
of great marketers.
What there aren't
are a lot of people
who are great marketers
or branders
who also know
how to monetize.
That's what makes you
a great entrepreneur.
You know, it's just not
a great investment.
I mean, I would do anything
to be in business with you
going forward,
but only getting 5% for every
$10 million in cash flow
is not enough
for me to get excited.
I think you'd be
an amazing partner.
Is there a percentage that
you would feel like you
had skin in the game
and could be a partner
for me in this?
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out.
Kaylin has an offer
on the table from Kevin,
and Mark seems interested,
but he is struggling with
the small 5% stake
she is offering for
her puzzle company, Jiggy.
Is there a percentage that
you would feel like
you had skin in the game
and could be a partner for me
in this?
I mean, it'd have
to be 15%.
Would you scale
an investment with that
at $1.5 million for 15%?
No.
Because it's still
the same math, right?
It's linear
at that point.
What would you counter for 10%?
It'd have to be
the 15%, 'cause remember ‐‐
Kaylin,
15% is a good deal.
Yeah, 'cause
that's the difference
between when you get to
$10 million in profit,
making $500,000 in return.
Totally, totally.
Yeah, you know
the math.
But we have a clear
line of sight ‐‐
I thought he was
going to say 25%.
[ Chuckles ]
I'm serious.
I haven't even told you about
what we're gonna do next year.
We're going to do $5 million
and net 2 of that.
The unit economics work.
I want growth capital
and to accelerate it,
but the business is working,
and we're self‐funding.
You just need capital,
is what I just heard you say.
No, Kaylin, you
do not need capital.
Jump start. Growth capital.
This is a very
rare situation.
Take his half a million
dollars for 15% to you,
as secondary shares.
Doesn't go into
the business.
It goes into
your pocket.
Why is this
a good idea?
Because you're gonna
walk more confident.
take more risks.
Because you're gonna have
that little nest egg.
The business doesn't
need the cash,
and you have a Mark Cuban
that's gonna help you.
Are you saying that Mark is
gonna give the money to her?
He writes
a $500,000 check,
and it goes into
her pocket.
Mark, what do
you say?
Because her business
is so great.
It's great having Daniel
negotiate for you, Mark.
Cuban: So, Kaylin,
what do you think?
I've never seen
that before.
Look, he's right.
$500,000 in your pocket,
living in New York,
when you've been
stressing this whole time
is not a bad thing.
But then, on the flip side,
how much of an accelerant
would it be
to the business?
Because if you can get enough
of a multiple on that,
then it could be worth
$10 million, $20 million,
$30 million
in your pocket.
Yes. Yes.
That's the decision.
But you own 100% of it.
Yes, I do.
If we could bring
the investment up
to get to that 15% ‐‐
It's not that you need
more capital.
It's something that
you feel you want
because you set
a threshold, right?
[ Sighs ]
You know, 15 is more than
I was hoping to go to today.
And...
That's why they
call it "Shark Tank."
[ Chuckles ] I know.
I watch the show.
I knew that. Um...
I have an ask
on top of the offer.
As you know, we're
a mission‐driven company
dedicated to supporting artists.
Will you match our
fundraising efforts this year,
if I meet at your 15%?
And what do you
anticipate raising?
We've done 20 so far.
I want to go over 50.
So, just match
the $50,000?
Okay, easy.
Okay.
Got a deal?
We have a deal!
Done!
Aaaah!
Great job, Kaylin.
Thank you all.
‐I can't wait.
‐Good job.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Kaylin, you are amazing.
‐This will be exciting.
‐Thank you. Thank you.
Congratulations.
I didn't get
to give you my offer.
I know, Lori. I'm sorry.
All good.
Empowering female artists
is such a part of our mission,
and now with Mark on our team
and this wind at our backs,
we can scale that impact
across the world.
The only risk
you've got is
does it roll over
after COVID?
No, I invested
in her.
Herjavec: She was
phenomenal.
This business
may roll over.
This business.
Fine.
We pivot and go to
something else.
♪♪
Narrator:
Last season, Kelley Higney
and her mom Ellen McAlister
make a deal with Lori Greiner
for their insect‐bite
relief tool, Bug Bite Thing.
I don't do this often.
I'm offering you
my Golden Ticket.
We'd like to do
a deal with you.
Thank you!
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
Higney: There is no greater
platform in the world
to launch a business
than "Shark Tank."
The year before pitching
to the Sharks,
we did $500,000
in sales.
A year and a half
after making our deal,
we have done
over $11 million in sales.
We went from 2 employees
to 30 employees,
and we moved into a 10,000
square foot warehouse.
We are going to be
in over 25,000 retail locations,
including Walmart,
Lowe's, Home Depot,
Ace Hardware, Jo‐Ann Fabrics,
and so many more.
Can one product
change your life?
We're living
testimonials of that.
Bug Bite Thing is so superior
because it's not a chemical,
there's nothing harmful
about it,
and it actually really works.
McAlister: We continue to be
Amazon's number‐one product
for insect bite relief,
and we have over 30,000
four‐ and five‐star reviews.
That means it works.
It works.
Exactly.
The feedback that is on
these reviews are not just,
"Wow,
this works great."
It's, "Where has this
been my entire life?"
We're projected to do an
additional $15 million in sales
by the end of the year.
25,000 retail locations.
That's what everybody dreams of.
You guys did it.
Higney: This business
means everything to me.
I feel with
the deepest passion
that this is what
I was born to do,
that I need to
get this product
in every household
in the world,
that people need a more
effective way to get relief.
It's a huge problem,
And we're out here providing
that solution to them,
and it's the most
rewarding thing.
I love my job.
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Kessler: Alright, this is it.
[ Inhaling deeply ]
Ain't no better time
than now, boys.
than now.
Ain't no better
time than now.
Let's do it.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is an innovation
in the cleaning space.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Matt.
I'm Jeff.
And I'm Tyler.
And we're seeking
$100,000
in exchange for 10% of our
company called the Scrubbie.
It's called
the what?
The Scrubbie!
Now, Sharks,
almost everyone
has a kitchen
sink sprayer
and probably tried using it
to clean off dishes
at one time
or another.
The problem is, to get the last
bit of food off your plate,
you're going to end up
scratching your fine china.
Oh, no!
And you're probably gonna get
a little wet in the process.
The Scrubbie is a universal
cleaning attachment
that turns your
ordinary sink sprayer
into a supercharged
cleaning machine.
By harnessing
high‐pressure water
and putting a scrubbing
attachment right
where you need it,
the Scrubbie
cuts down cleaning time
and conserves water.
And since you're not physically
touching the scrubber,
you can clean
using hot water
with no worries about
burning your hands.
Oh!
Not only that,
the Scrubbie's gonna adapt
to your newer, pull‐down
style faucets, as well.
‐Say what?!
‐You heard it here.
The Scrubbie's center piece
will pop out and reverse.
With its flexible,
tapered interior ridges,
it'll attach in a flash
and be ready to rock.
But wait, Sharks.
Together: There's more!
Darn right,
there is.
Check this out.
The Scrubbie has
a threaded interior,
so you can
take it outdoors
and screw it right on
your garden hose.
That's right, Sharks.
Use it to clean off
your outdoor tables and chairs,
your car wheels and tires,
your windows and doors,
your boat, your coolers,
your ‐‐ your birdbath.
Okay, Tyler.
We get it.
Indoors or out, the Scrubbie
will handle the chore.
And we're confident
that with your help,
we can make this
a success.
Now, which one of
you Sharks
is ready to
clean house with ‐‐
Together: The Scrubbie!
[ Chuckles ]
Good job, guys.
So, is this
interchangeable?
So this is your
scratchy side,
this is your
soft side.
Yes, exactly.
And then it's disposable.
You just throw it away?
Disposable as well.
It comes with...
And you get refills.
It comes with
three sponges.
How much does it cost?
$14.99 is what
we're selling it for.
And what are
the replacement sponges?
Well, we're selling them for
$9.99 for three of them,
and that's on
a subscription base,
so every two months,
you get three sponges.
A Scrubbie subscription?
Scrubbie subscription.
I bet Scrub Daddy
doesn't have subscriptions.
They don't need to.
O'Leary: Guys, can I just make
a comment about it?
First time
I've ever seen it.
It's ugly.
I mean, it looks very,
very industrial to me.
Hosey: If we wanted to
spend more money on it,
we could have created
a better model,
but we wanted to get
our margins, costs lower.
So with this unit, we're paying
hardly next to nothing for it.
We paid $3.16.
Is it a prototype?
These are
manufactured units.
O'Leary:
What kind of sales we got?
Okay, so 2019 ‐‐
the Scrubbie's
an amazing product.
It's one‐of‐a‐kind.
It's the first of its kind.
Do you have a patent?
When we get the adjectives,
there's no number, that's bad.
Yes, we have two patents,
and one in the
application process.
Utility patent?
One utility patent
and one pending.
So, guys, tell us
about sales.
Is there a number?
So, 2019, we did a launch
at a local trade show
in Wichita, and we killed it ‐‐
everybody loved it.
What's "killed it"?
O'Leary: And?
So in those two days, we sold
a couple hundred Scrubbies.
How many dollars?
So, in dollar sense,
what we made at the show?
No, just give me 2019 sales.
What did you sell?
I've asked you five times.
So, total,
we sold 868 Scrubbies.
How many dollars is that?
That is right around
$13,000.
Ohh.
Now, what's this year
gonna look like?
Yep, sales wise, we ‐‐
we, business‐wise,
we did
some online marketing.
We didn't have
enough funds to do...
Last year.
...a successful online
marketing campaign and content.
It's never good
when Mr. Wonderful,
who loves numbers,
asks you what were
sales in 2019?
What are sales in 2020?
I mean, just give me
a number.
Right, so, total sales
to date is 868.
Dollars?
868 Scrubbies.
Tyler, why can't you answer
Kevin's question?
Yeah, no, so, totally ‐‐
Tell us your
forecast for this year.
Sales this year,
the forecast for this year,
if we are predictive
from other companies
that want to do
business with us,
their projection's
that we will do
around $320,000 this year.
Yeah, so they're just guessing.
There's no real there there.
Right? That's the problem.
That's why you're here.
So have you sold
to any stores
and put these up
at stores?
We haven't sold
to any stores, no.
We're not in retail.
Greiner:
So, I'm curious.
Have you been watching
"Shark Tank" a long time?
Yes.
Yes, seen a lot
of them.
Greiner: Seen a lot
Who did your packaging
and your logo?
One of our graphic designers.
It was a friend of mine.
I want to go back to numbers.
So, I have a question.
And I only have
two questions ‐‐
Kevin.
Lori, I got the patent thing.
Why did you so
rudely interrupt me?
Remember, Lori, I'm working
on anger management this season.
I know, and your
anger management classes
are not working.
I just ‐‐ I can't
take it anymore.
I have to ask a question.
Oh, my God.
You are so rude.
Very simple.
Just two numbers.
I'm begging for two numbers.
Lifetime sales to date.
$13,000.
No, all in.
So, lifetime sales
is $13,000.
This business is not worth
a million dollars.
In February, we got pretty
excited at the trade show.
We were the busiest
booth there.
We must have had 50 people
come up to us
and tell us, "You guys
need to be on 'Shark Tank.'"
Why didn't you sell it?
We got the call
the very next day
to get on "Shark Tank."
Cuban: You still could
keep on selling.
Look, guys, do you know
what a 24,000 box score is?
It's when a guy
plays 24 minutes
and gets zero points,
zero assists, and zero rebounds.
Wow.
It's noteworthy because
if you play 24 minutes,
something should
fall in your lap, right?
A ball should come
your way, roll your way.
You accidentally trip
and pass the ball.
You guys sold nothing.
You guys are
a 24,000 box score.
Because just out of chance,
some lightning,
something should have been sold,
and you couldn't find
a way to sell anything.
Dakin: We had
the opportunity.
We were approached
by a company
that did want ‐‐
No, no, no,
that's not the point.
That's not the point.
It's that ourselves
should have gone out ‐‐
Yeah.
We wanted to go out
and knock on every door
that we possibly could,
but we also wanted
to protect our idea.
So we went back to
our patent attorney
and claimed everything.
It doesn't matter!
‐We wanted to ‐‐
‐If I have to tell you ‐‐
‐It doesn't matter!
It's just another excuse.
Cuban: It doesn't matter!
Right. Look, I've heard every
eeny‐meeny‐miny‐mo excuse, guys.
We wanted to...
I'm out.
Does it not bother you that you
designed something that looks,
from a logo,
name perspective,
almost exactly like another
product Lori invested in
that shall remain nameless?
You think it looks similar to ‐‐
It doesn't bother you?
I mean, the name kind of
sounds the same,
but that's not the same.
Okay, so I'm glad that
Robert brought that up.
Not necessarily.
I was about to before I was
so rudely interrupted.
Are you going to sue them
into the Stone Age?
So, wait,
here's the thing, guys.
Your logo is so close
to Scrub Daddy's.
You used the same
font, right?
But Scrub Daddy? Scrubbie?
Hosey: For the record,
we thought of this
before Scrub Daddy
existed.
Did you think about this
while you were doing it?
Not at all.
It never crossed your mind?
'Cause it's really,
very coincidental...
Really?
...that it's
the same font.
Honestly, no.
When our designer
came up with this,
we thought
it looked great.
When your logo's really close,
I don't like that,
and I don't want confusion
on the market.
‐So ‐‐
‐I'm out.
The ‐‐ The Scrub Daddy
doesn't have an attachment
that connects to
your sink sprayer.
And you also don't
have to use your hands.
Our is not the sponge.
It is the attachment.
The future of our product,
we foresee different attachments
for different purposes
to be able to
screw onto the Scrubbie.
Yeah, with a plastic thread,
you can have the car Scrubbie,
the dog Scrubbie.
Guys, I actually found this
intriguing.
But, you know, when I started my
first company out of law school,
PeaceWorks, to promote peace
between Arabs and Israelis,
there was not a period
of one day, let alone one year,
where I just waited.
Like, it was about survival.
I had to figure it out.
We didn't ‐‐
And I eventually decoded it.
We didn't have to wait.
And the fact that you went
for such a long period
trying to figure things out
concerns me a great deal.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Yeah, guys,
you know, to that point,
I mean, to me, there's
two types of entrepreneurs.
There's the hungry,
and there's the satisfied,
and you've been doing this
for two years.
You don't have that
desperation of hunger
that you wake up
and you got to sell, man.
Right. So ‐‐
I'm out.
Guys, I‐I really
was underwhelmed.
I think you could have done
a better job with this.
One of you guys
has to sell this stuff.
I am an investor.
I have $100,000.
I have no reason
to give it to you.
I'm out.
So I know the decisions
that we make today
define us tomorrow,
so, I mean,
we're gonna go out, and we're
gonna hit it hard.
Take care, guys.
Good luck.
You guys will
figure it out.
You'll be seeing us.
I hope so, guys.
Good luck, guys.
Really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Not quite how they
wanted it to go.
[ Chuckles ]
No.
Get off your butt
and sell.
It's good to dream.
It's better to hustle.
Well, darn.
Yep.
Well, we're going to
sell more Scrubbies.
They compared us a lot
to the Scrub Daddy,
but the only thing
we have in common
is that the ability to make
hundreds of millions of dollars,
and we know within
the next few years or less,
we're gonna
reach that goal.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an indulgent version
of a health food trend.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks,
I'm Cassandra Ayala,
and I'm here today with one
of my three beautiful daughters.
Hi, Sharks.
I'm India.
Both: And we're the Bumbling Bee
Vegan Junk Food and Burger Bar.
[ Chuckles ]
Sharks, we're here today
looking for $150,000
for 10%
of our company.
Sharks, when you think
of vegan food,
do you think
bland and boring?
Well, we are crushing that myth
that plant‐based food
has to be just
twigs and berries.
Our vegan junk food
is unlike anything
you've ever had before.
Whether it's our
juicy Clucker,
a double‐dip
fried chicken sandwich...
Mm. We got that.
...our award‐winning
Coney Island chili cheese dogs
with the hand‐cut
Cajun fries,
or a fat, juicy burger
dripping with
our creamy
cheddar cheese sauce.
Yum!
Don't forget to
finish it off
with one of our
sweet nectar milkshakes.
The Bumbling Bee
Junk Food and Burger Bar
is the new generation
of fast food.
Whether you're
dairy‐free, vegan,
vegetarian
or flexitarian ‐‐
Or just a little
herbivore‐curious.
[ Both laugh ]
Both:
There's something for everyone.
And, now, our mom
is our queen bee.
That's me.
But we do need some more
honey to help us
pollinate hives
across the country.
Sharks...
Both: To "bee" or not to "bee"?
That is the question.
‐Aha.
‐[ Laughs ] Cute.
You've got some rapping skills
there, don't you?
[ Both laugh ]
Hang on.
This is all vegan?
Yes.
Cassandra:
All of that is vegan.
100%.
Every bit.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Yay!
The mac and cheese
is really good.
We have won the award
for Best Hot Dog in our area.
And I don't mean
Best Vegan Hot Dog.
We won Best Hot Dog.
India: Hot dog.
But it's not your hot dog.
You must get...
It's not our hot dog.
It's what we do with it.
We put our
magic spin on it.
So tell us about
the restaurant.
Absolutely.
We have two restaurants.
India runs
Virginia Beach, Virginia.
My other daughter, Olivia,
who couldn't be here today,
runs Boulder, Colorado.
We decided to become
a vegan company
at the beginning
of 2019.
What were you
before that?
I was a real estate
investment broker.
Flipped a lot of houses
with my husband.
Unfortunately,
I got trapped,
and that was
the market crash.
So when
the market crashed,
I had $10,000
to my name.
So I went and I said,
"What can I do with this money?"
So I started with a food cart,
a hot dog cart,
took my money
from the hot dog cart,
bought a trailer.
Took the money
from the trailer,
bought a truck.
And I got it
to the point
where I had four trucks
plus a backup truck.
Four. [ Laughs ] Yep.
And I got to the point
where it wasn't
worth it to me
anymore
to kill myself
for that kind of money,
if my kids weren't interested
in being part of it.
I needed something that
my daughters could be a part of.
So that's when I said to them,
"What is it gonna take
to get you
passionate about this?"
My other daughter, Lexi,
was a healthy vegan.
What's missing
in the market?
Junk food.
Well, can I ask
you your economics?
Yes.
Because in order to
franchise,
you have to be able
to operate at about
17% to 20% pre‐tax profit
per location.
We are at a 15% margin.
Last year, switched over
with our first truck in June.
Then we opened up our
brick and mortar,
which was my commissary,
in October.
That's what you want? You want
more brick and mortars, right?
No, I want both.
Tell me your sales
for last year.
$194,000 for one truck
part‐time
and one brick and mortar
that opened in October.
Now, what's this year
gonna look like?
$324,000 came from
Virginia Beach, Virginia,
which was closed
for six weeks?
Yes.
And Boulder, Colorado,
which opened January 16th
and closed April 4th
and reopened July 25th.
And with that, we also
pulled back our food trucks.
Right, we had to pull back
our food trucks
because events
were canceled.
And how are you doing that?
You're still open, or...?
Yes.
Heck, yeah.
Greiner:
You have huge spunk...
Thank you!
...and passion
and obviously grit.
I mean, lots of words
come to mind with you.
Firecracker.
I love her.
Firecracker, right?
So where do you think
you get your drive from?
My parents separated
when I was very early.
My mother was a ‐‐
she's recovering now,
for almost 50 years,
but she was
an alcoholic,
and I grew up in
the homeless shelters.
I learned how to
dumpster dive
at 8 years old
to get my food.
But that led me
to understand
that I wanted to be
a stronger person.
I wanted to have control
of where I went in my life.
I will never
be hungry.
I will never not know
how to make money.
And I don't think that
I would change anything,
because I would not be
the woman I am today.
That's a great story.
Good for you. Well done.
‐Thank you.
‐Yeah, good for you.
‐Congratulations.
That's, you know,
they say the strongest swords
are forged in
the hottest fires.
You're beaming.
India, how proud are you
of your mother?
[ Laughs ]
I love her.
She's amazing.
Thank you.
[ Voice breaking ] Like I said,
she's a firecracker.
Aren't my girls
awesome?
Lubetzky:
I find you so inspiring
and the challenges
that you overcame,
but for me, I don't see
enough differentiation
between other things
that I've seen.
I'm not completely
drawn to the food.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
There's not that one
thing that makes it
impossible to copy,
right?
Your execution,
your relentlessness
will make it successful.
Anybody can
copy McDonald's.
But McDonald's also
started in 1955...
Right.
...and was one of the first
with drive‐throughs.
Yes, and we're one of the first
vegan junk foods.
Well, yeah,
and that's true,
but again, you haven't
gotten that scale yet
where you can say
to everybody else,
"We don't care what you do."
Right?
Right.
Which just makes it
very hard.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Herjavec:
Cassandra, amazing job.
I mean, you know, one of
the great things about business,
it gives you the freedom
to do the things you love
and spend the time
with your family.
Absolutely.
I will tell you, in California,
I've seen this.
Yes.
And it's a race ‐‐ Whether
you realize it or not,
you're not the first one.
You're not the only one.
There's lots of them.
That's right.
And I would never
bet against you
and the Bumblebee family.
But as a business,
I don't know if it's
ready for an investment
until you get to
a critical point of scale.
Only for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
I think that it would be smarter
for you to not expand,
to stay solid and grow
what you have right now.
I'm not going to invest.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
We appreciate it.
Cassandra, I really connected
with your story,
'cause I lost my father
when he was 37.
I was raised by my mother,
and she was very tough.
But I learned from what she did,
that that gives you power.
So, for you, obviously,
you've earned that.
It gets me emotional
just thinking about it.
But your numbers,
they're not investable.
You need to make at least
$500,000 per location
on a 20% pre‐tax profit.
And, you know, I try
and keep the discipline
of not letting my emotions
tug me into a deal
that doesn't make
economic sense,
and that's the only reason
I'm out.
Well, I do hope that you will
all come and eat at it.
Absolutely.
It's our pleasure
to have been picked by you.
You guys are amazing.
Congratulations
on all you've accomplished.
Thank you.
Bye.
♪♪
It's okay, right?
Yeah.
I am the woman
that I am today
because of what
I've been through
and where
I've come from.
I've raised
my daughters
to be the women
they are today
based on that.
Yeah, I don't think
we're ever gonna stop.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is what
the entrepreneurs believe
is a better version of
a common household necessity.
♪♪
Hola. I'm Keidy.
And I'm Gene.
And we're the makers
of the XTorch.
We are seeking
$150,000
in exchange for 10%
of our business.
Imagine the power
goes out at home
and everything goes dark,
or else you're camping
and your cellphone dies
just when you
need it most.
Sharks,
let us break the ice
and introduce you to
the XTorch.
[ Laughs ]
Herjavec: Whoa. Wow.
Greiner: Wow.
Look at that.
After more than two days
of being frozen
in a block of ice,
it still works.
The XTorch is a super‐tough
light and power device
designed to handle even
the most rugged of conditions.
It is solar‐powered,
rechargeable,
and it has
three functions.
It works as
a flashlight,
a lantern,
and a cellphone charger.
And I know what
you're thinking, Sharks.
Another solar flashlight?
But the XTorch
is so much more.
It can hold its charge up to
three years in storage,
supply up to 48 hours'
worth of light.
It glows in the dark,
and it even floats.
Best of all,
our company donates
at least
25% of our profits
to our partners
around the globe.
We want to see
the XTorch in every home,
workplace,
and campsite in America,
because when
the power goes out,
everybody needs
reliable backup power.
So, Sharks, who wants to
partner with us
and help us
light the world ‐‐
Both: With the XTorch?
[ Chuckling ] Good job.
Ta‐da!
So, how do you
turn this on?
Oh, here,
let me show you.
Well, here, see this
little button right here?
It's the
on/off button.
At the top? Yeah.
Press it down one time.
Uh‐huh.
And that's a flashlight.
Press it again,
that's a room lantern.
Lubetzky: Whoa.
Oh, I see.
Gene: Yeah.
Wow.
And you press it
a third time,
and you get
a table lantern.
Keidy: Or a work
lantern.
Or a reading
Oh, like this.
Yes.
And if you notice,
press it one more time,
it all shuts off.
See these little
green lights here?
It tells you exactly how full
the battery is.
How long would it take
to fully charge, solar?
You stick it outside,
take about 22 hours.
For a full charge,
but ‐‐ but
you can also charge it
with electricity.
How long does it take you
to charge that way?
Only one hour.
About one hour.
But that's not all.
You can charge your
cellphone with it.
With a USB cable,
you plug it in,
and you can charge
your cellphone.
Greiner: I like that.
[ Spooky voice ]
Robert.
Robeeeeert.
Maaaaark.
Keviiiin.
Robeeeert.
Keidy: Oh.
Oh, look at that,
huh?
Oh, wow.
You guys look
very scary.
Especially Mr. Wonderful.
[ Chuckles ]
Herjavec: Look at this.
Look how bright that is.
If the ceiling were lower,
it would be way better.
And that's just
the table lantern.
Okay, best flashlight
in the world.
How much does it cost?
It costs $55.95 on our website,
and it costs...
55 ‐‐ Say it again.
$55.95 on our website.
That's pricy.
It costs us about
$18.50 to manufacture,
but in our next
manufacturing cost,
it'll cost us $14.
Gene and Keidy,
I have a couple questions.
Please.
Yes.
Most important,
you started, "Hola"...
Yes.
but I can't tell if you're
Latin American.
Where are you from?
I am from
the Dominican Republic.
Ah, Dominicana.
I grew up
in the Dominican Republic,
so I experienced
the lack of light.
And I'm sure, because
you grew up in Mexico...
Yes.
...power outages are very common
in Latin American countries.
Greiner: How did you
come up with this?
I lived in Africa
for a year.
We were working with
a food distribution NGO.
Where in Africa
were you living?
I'm sorry?
Equatorial Guinea.
And they speak
Spanish there.
Yeah.
He came to visit there, too,
and I got really sick,
and they didn't know if
it was dengue or malaria.
They didn't know
what it was.
So, I was there, these doctors
came in and they said,
"Hey, we don't know what
this is, but she's dying."
Ooh.
So they put an IV in her.
Herjavec: Wow.
She's under this mosquito net.
There's no power
in this whole community.
And they give me this bag
full of different‐colored pills
and says, "You have to
give your fiancée,
the love of your life,
these medications,
or she's going to die."
I'm in the middle of the night,
trying to read Spanish.
My Spanish was about
this big at that time,
and I've got this little,
pink flashlight
and I'm pounding it
against the wall
so I could figure out what pills
to give her at what time.
And then after awhile,
that flashlight ‐‐
of course, we've all
had this experience,
we ended up
throwing it away.
So I ended up
with a candle,
trying to read
all of this stuff.
Greiner: Wow.
She's, like, taking
her last breath.
Well, the end of the story
is that she survived.
I survived.
Yay!
That was the motivation
to make this unit?
It was.
That may be
the most dramatic reason
for the birth of a flashlight.
So how is yours
different
than any other flashlight
out there, or is it?
Ooh, don't get us
started on that.
Tell them.
I'm getting you started on this.
[ Laughter ]
Tell her!
First of all,
this is not a flashlight.
This is a solar‐power,
rechargeable
light and power device
that's used around the world
in the most rugged conditions
you could possibly imagine.
Otherwise known as
a flashlight.
No.
No, it's rechargeable.
[ Laughs ]
It's a light and power device
that will keep you safe
and your
family safe.
So it's the device formerly
known as a flashlight.
You are wrong.
Greiner: It's an
emergency light.
Listen, you go down and you buy
this $20, this $10 flashlight
at your hardware store,
you bring it back,
tell me, is it going to work as
a lantern, a table lantern?
Is it gonna
be solar‐powered?
No, but a $55 device might.
Gene, I don't think
that's the point.
Where my head goes with this
is, it's a flashlight,
but I think ‐‐ Wait.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
No!
Herjavec: Lori!
We've got to go to
the flashlight community
and ask them what they think.
Cuban: Okay, guys.
So, obviously, this is
a marketing play, right?
Because other people are
gonna say theirs is the best.
Yours is gonna
be the best.
You know, the difference is
in how you market it, right?
So tell us what
you're gonna do there.
Well, right now, of course,
we are in
30 different countries.
You are already?
That's right.
We are working with
nonprofit organizations
who use this to help
individuals
who suffer without light
and power.
O'Leary: Do you sell it
to the nonprofits?
Herjavec: Or do you give it
to them?
Well, we used to sell it
to the nonprofit,
but we changed
our business model.
Are you a charity,
or are you a business?
No, we are both.
We are a profit business.
Cuban: So, okay, you used
to sell to the NGOs.
Now you went commercial.
You want to sell these
to everyday people?
Yes.
We want to go to
brick and mortar.
Before, when our
cost was higher,
we didn't have
a comfortable margin
to get into
brick and mortar.
I would like to just get to
what you sold last year.
Last year, we sold
$53,000 worth of product.
$53,000?
Yes, sir.
And then this year,
what do you think?
$90,000.
So far, year‐to‐date, or that's
what you think you'll do?
That's what we think
we'll do.
How much have you done
year‐to‐date?
$36,000.
Oy.
When you started with
the NGOs in 30 countries,
when you were selling to them,
not giving it to them,
what were your sales then?
About $30,000
for the whole year.
For the whole year?
Yep. Yep.
Is there anything
proprietary in this tech?
We went on and bought every
single flashlight, lantern,
cellphone charger,
solar panel out there
and took them apart.
And we took all of the bad stuff
and we threw it out,
and we kept
the good stuff.
But, Gene, I give you credit,
you do better than anybody...
‐Hang on, Mark.
...of talking around a question
and not answering it.
You tell me
what the question is.
Is there anything
proprietary?
What is proprietary,
for example, is this ‐‐
see these little buttons
right here in the front lens?
Those are actually lenses
in there that we designed.
So you're saying
that's proprietary to you?
No, but we designed it.
The firmware, we designed.
So I feel like you're not
answering the question.
I'm not trying to be
rude to you,
but is it
proprietary or not?
Absolutely.
Explain to me what
"proprietary" means.
Meaning you own the rights to it
and nobody else can use it.
Greiner: Is it
intellectual property?
No, it's not.
Do you have a patent on it?
I don't have
a patent on it.
This product has merit,
good functionality.
It's way too expensive.
The way to make money with this
is to figure out a way
to go direct‐to‐consumer,
online only.
Forget retail.
$29.95.
That's probably the magic price.
There's no other way,
because you are in
an incredibly competitive space.
I think $29 ‐‐ it might
even have to be $19.
I don't know till we test.
Mm‐hmm.
But I don't need a job.
I'm ‐‐ I'm busy.
I want you to do this ‐‐
I want you to say "Make money."
Please say it.
Okay, "Make money."
"Make money."
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you
for your consideration.
Oh, okay.
So, guys,
you've got a great product.
Thank you.
But you've got to be able
to sell that product.
Yes.
And you haven't been able
to demonstrate yet
by your sales
or anything you've said
that you have
a path and a plan
where you're going to be able
to blow these things out, right?
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
I'm in complete agreement.
I like the product.
I think it's
a good product,
but would I pay $60 for it?
I don't think so,
and for that reason, I'm out.
Okay.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
What she said.
Herjavec:
What did she say?
[ Speaking Spanish ]
"Please make sure Robert
gives us a good offer."
Keidy,
the sales are awful.
There's just a lack
of understanding
of how to get this
to the market.
You either have to be
the world's toughest torch
and go higher‐end,
or be the world's best
low‐end flashlight
with some features.
You're kind of
in the middle.
Gene: Mm‐hmm.
You can't be in the middle.
You're gonna get crushed.
I love the product, but I
don't want to be your partner.
I want to buy
the entire company.
Whoa.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Robert is not impressed
with Gene and Keidy's
business acumen,
but he does see promise in their
solar‐powered light, XTorch.
I don't want to be your partner.
I want to buy
the entire company.
Whoa.
I'll give you $400,000
for 100% of the business.
♪♪
No. We would take
a million.
Whoa!
We have connections
and credibility
with nonprofit organizations,
all over the world ‐‐
But you don't have sales, Gene.
We don't have sales
because we have been timid...
Yet.
...in pursuing that
because it's just us.
We've done no marketing.
Sales is not for the timid.
Sales is a contact sport.
That's why we
need a partner.
That's why we need
a mentor to help us.
We need ‐‐
Lubetzky: So they said
one million.
You had said
$400,000.
I can't get to a million.
I would go up
to $500,000.
Greiner: Wow.
Ohh!
It got interesting
all of a sudden.
‐Seriously, Gene, this is not ‐‐
‐Well, maybe what I have to say
might help you
with your decision.
Gene: Please.
I think it's a really
good product. It's clever.
You took all the things that you
thought somebody would want,
almost like
a Swiss Army knife,
you put it all into this.
I think the problem,
for me, comes with
that there's a lot of
competition out there
that, you know, you probably
know do really big things.
Yes, but...
And they're very,
very powerful.
It's just not investable
for me. I'm sorry. I'm out.
Can we ‐‐ Okay.
Keidy, there's nothing
proprietary.
I know.
There's no IP.
So why do you
want it, Robert?
You've done
$40,000 to $50,000 in sales.
So why would
you buy it?
I see a vision of it.
I do see a branding
exercise with it.
Gene, are you saying
no to my offer?
$750,000.
‐Oh!
‐Bam!
That's as low as
we would go, right there.
I'm sorry, no. There's no
way I'm going up to that!
Cuban: So what are you
gonna do, Robert?
Oh, I'm definitely out.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Congrats on your success.
‐Okay. Bye now.
‐Bye‐bye. Bye. Thank you.
Lubetzky:
Good luck.
♪♪
Gene: We feel like we've got
the best device in the world.
We're not ready
to just say,
"Yes, here, take our
baby away from us."
No, we wanted to be
part of the process.
We wanted to grow the company
with a mentor, with a partner.
[ Chuckles ] Whoo!
$500,000?
Are you out of your mind?
I like the product.
Like, come on.
[ Sharks laugh, scream ]
You want how much?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪